back in the late 60s and early 70s we
were experimenting with touch how does a
piece of glass know it's being touched
where it's being touched what happens
when you hit it with multiple fingers
and a lot of people thought it was quite
silly they said well how could you have
an interface where you're covering up
the thing you're pointing at and isn't
going to get covered with fingerprints
and people laughed but now the the touch
screen and multi-touch turned into
iPhone and iPad and sort of the idea
that you're not you know just using a
mouse in a keyboard ian was invented
here and that eventually becomes a
Kindle and is driving all kinds of
low-cost displays of Pebble watch and
things like that but that field of
working with very small materials at the
molecular level has spawned a whole new
area which is the ability to print genes
on the semiconductor on a chip to
massively scale the ability to do in
synthesis Lego Mindstorms that was
invented here at the Media Lab as the
conversions of software and hardware so
it's the idea that you can kind of put
Legos together and that young kids can
hack robots another one is scratch which
is a programming language for kids kids
will learn to code and that learning to
code is a very important way to have
kids become excited about creating their
own works robotic prostheses developed
in Hugh Harris biomechatronics lab and
that's part of a larger initiative
called the center for extreme Bionic who
eliminate all disabilities whether their
brain disabilities or organ failure or
limbs Guitar Hero which is a game that
many of you may have played also
originated here at the Media Lab opto
neurogenetics you can put photosynthetic
sensors on to the nerves inside of the
eye and actually make a blind Mouse see
and we will hopefully be seeing this
applied for human beings to your
blindness a lot of the initial wearable
work was done here at the Media Lab in
the 80s that group evolves into things
like Google glass and the Samsung
watches and all the different sorts of
wearables that are common now many of
the people who lead those groups come
from the Media Lab
so the car GPS system was originally a
project called backseat driver when they
tried to patent it the MIT technology
licensing office said oh that would be
too full of risk no one would ever
actually build that and we ended up not
patenting it even though we invented the
car GPS GPS and cars have become a
common thing that everybody has but that
continues too much forward into things
like self-driving cars which are going
to become a very important piece and a
lot of the work around AI and data and
things like that are things that we're
still working on and actually we just
recently published a study by one of our
researchers about the ethics around how
self-driving cars will make decisions
and things like that so we continue to
be interested in both mobility and its
relationship to data and its interface
to human beings I'm very fond of telling
people I've been to the future I've been
to the future dozens of times partly
because so many times I said well in 10
years this will happen and then of
course the 10 years things do happen I
think each of the innovations are
important but I think more important
than anything is we're creating a new
way of thinking about innovation and a
new way of thinking about designing
things we don't do things that other
people would do we find a lot of
opportunity in these spaces either
between or beyond existing disciplines
and I think that that's going to be
tremendously important as we get into a
world that's very complex and where
everything is connected together these
sorts of creative people are really
important so it's the DNA of the lab I
think is more important than any
specific technology that's come out